if he joined the air force for glory
abhinandan vartaman undoubtedly got what
he wanted
a national hero in his native india the
wing commander now also has a whole
gallery devoted to him
in pakistan though clearly for different
reasons
the indian pilot made international
headlines after he was shot down in a
dogfight
and captured by the pakistani military
during a major standoff with
india earlier this year
now the pilot's uniform as well as other
sea's personal belongings
are on show at the pakistan air force
museum in karachi
it's an unashamed tribute to what
curators and visitors see as proof of
pakistani military might
and it's leaving school children and
students with their eyes aglow
all of his belongings were confiscated
and they are now on display here at the
museum
it felt very good today to see all these
articles on display
we are proud of the pakistan air force
the exhibition also features debris of
the downed indian fighter jet
a reminder that the incident at the
heart of it was serious
following a suicide attack in indian
kashmir
india and pakistan conducted tit-for-tat
airstrikes in each other's territory in
february
and analysts raised the alarm that the
skirmish could turn into an
all-out wall
tensions calmed when pakistan freed
bataman from captivity
and handed him back to india but the
hype around the pilot
didn't die down neither did the
nationalist further
that his capture had fueled on both
sides of the border
at the exhibition many visitors are
feeling as patriotic
as ever the pakistani army did a good
thing
and they have made us proud they have
filled us with enthusiasm so we can
fight with courage and pride if someone
dares to attack us
and we can say proudly that we're
pakistani and we are no less than anyone
else
the legendary story of wing commander
abhinandan vartaman
a source of national pride for both
india and pakistan
well the exhibit has sparked a flurry of
reaction on
social media let's take a look at a
tweet from an indian user in
delhi now who writes uh that pakistanis
have become great fans of wing commander
abhinandan who spoke like a boss even
under the most trying and
intimidating conditions inside an enemy
country as a pow
after all statues are built for heroes
here's a response from a user
located in england with a pakistani take
on the exhibit saying
of course we love abhipai he really
enjoyed our fantastic tea and he didn't
say anything bad about pakistan
when we sent back through the land
border we can always invite him again
when he brings us another plane and
fancy's more
fantastic tea
all right words brewing with sarcasm on
both sides there for more on the story
we're joined by dw asia correspondent
gelani hi shazam good to see you it
seems like this exhibit really has
triggered strong reactions both in
india and in pakistan what do you make
of all this
that's right and it's a predictable
banter between
people on either side of the border
i was in pakistan when this episode took
place back in
february and i can tell you that the
mood was really grim in pakistan
after indian jets struck deep inside the
pakistani territory
but within 24 to 48 hours when pakistan
shot down
indian air jets and captured wing
commander abhinandan
the mood changed now at the time if you
remember pakistan took a moral high
ground and they said we will return
him and they did but they made sure to
play with the optics you know
they filmed him while in custody uh they
paraded him in front of live
television when he was handed over so
pakistan has tried to
make the most of this opportunity in
terms of propaganda war
and that continues to this day what do
you think pakistan's aim is here with
this exhibit is it precisely playing
with optics
it is and i mean the two countries are
in some ways a mirror image of each
other
it happens on the indian side too if you
look at the indian film industry
bollywood
you look at social media there are all
these memes going on
jokes going on uh and that it's about
one-upmanship
um and pakistan uh played it
some would say slightly better in terms
of optics and now it is trying to make
the most of it but i feel sorry for
these school children we were looking at
uh i mean imagine uh you know what kind
of
perception they are growing up with that
you know they have the biggest neighbor
uh and they're being encouraged to view
them as their enemy
uh and it is again like i said happening
on both sides of the border
uh which does not auger well for future
relations
you know as you said there were memes
and jokes there was so much about the
story that went viral from you know the
gunslinger mustache this fantastic cup
of tea
but what has happened with the tensions
that led to that moment
especially with kashmir
so since february when we thought the
two countries came really close to
a war like situation obviously in
kashmir
india has pressed ahead effectively
annexing that region dividing it into in
two parts
pakistan has condemned it they've raised
it on diplomatic level
but there's not much pakistan can do and
pakistan is under tremendous pressure
not to respond in terms of encouraging
violence in kashmir
and the prime minister and the
government has reassured the world
community that they will not
retaliate in that way so it's a it's a
difficult situation for kashmiris
i think we will know the next steps will
be that when india lifts all these
restrictions in kashmir and what the
reaction is locally
without external interference but the
situation remains tense
all right dw correspondent shahzab
jilani thank you so much